yeah it's a very different picture to
the north of where we are here in
lerwick at the moment it is another day
a fourth day without power for
2400 homes here on uh Shetland they have
been off since Monday frustration is
growing anger is growing and patience I
think among many here is wearing thin
Engineers did manage to reconnect around
400 properties yesterday afternoon but
there has been huge logistical
challenges getting Engineers to this
part of the world because of the
geography of exactly where it is but 125
Engineers making their way by helicopter
and by ferry to Shetland to help with
this major effort to reconnect thousands
of properties they told us that they are
expecting to make progress on that today
but there is a warning from officials
here that it could now be into the
weekend before everyone is back on the
grid and fully connected the scale of
the damage has been severe you are
seeing the pictures of exactly the
extent of the damage the worst people
here are seeing in 20 years helicopters
are continuing to survey the scene
survey those polls that have gone down
like matchsticks in that extreme weather
because the snow and ice caused the uh
pulls to have extreme weight on them and
to eventually snap the Emergency
Shelters have been set up one man I was
speaking to last night said he couldn't
even make a 999 call so that shows you
just how dangerous a situation this is
for the people living here and there are
questions about just how sustainable
this is going forward the infrastructure
should be underground rather than over
ground at this point and there will be
questions about that going forward the
debrief will come but for now this is an
area still in an emergency footing